(Thud, beast roars) HUH! WHAT THE FUCK! HI?! I'M NOT IN MY SHIP! OOOOOH!
Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now, by some amazing stroke of luck, with the official full release of this game, my save game file still works.
Which means, that I am in a great position
In the middle of the ocean, surrounded by nothing, but death and only (laughs) darkness awaits me!
But, this is the full release of the game.
This is what I've been waiting for. This is what we've all been waiting for because now...
We can get the hell off of this damn ocean planet!
(Maniacal laughter)
Number one: I need to get back to my shit, which is way over there. Big Box Berry is in the ocean-
What is that?
Well, I have a new message
I'm sure this is gonna be good!
Hello?
Robotic voice: This is an automated distress signal from Lifepod 12, co-ordinates attached.
Robotic Voice: Warning: Lifepod has sunk beyond safe diving distance. Do not attempt retrieval without submersible support.
Automated female voice: Signal location uploaded to PDA.
Okay? Alright, then. Well!
That sucks for them!
They can suck a big ol' donger because I ain't gonna come their way
...And I'm pretty sure they're dead no matter what happens.
Now, where we are I'm not 100% sure. But Bubblebutt is right there.
Which means that we have a mode of transportation and things don't look so dire, but number one I gotta say
Before I start anything, I'm really happy that this game is fully released.
I was tempted to start over, all over again
I really was
To play from the beginning
But I've already done that and I've come so far in this one
And I've taken so much time and patience to be able to do this, that I've kind of gotten to this point where
I'm in love with the game. I really am. I hate the ocean! Oh, don't get me wrong!
I hate the ocean and we're gonna have to explore a lot of stuff that we've seen already anyway
And I'm gonna set out some objectives that we got to do, but it is good to be back
It is really really good to be back. It's good to see this game finally released. They've done tons of optimizations to the game
They've made it polished. They've actually fully released it with the storyline all intact. Everything on the Aurora that is able to be gotten
is available over there, which means that
Number one: I'm gonna go back to the Aurora.
Number two: I'm gonna retrieve all my shit.
Number three: I'm gonna start farming up materials.
And number four: We are gonna launchie the hellie out of here
(mumbling) Where's this...
Here! We are gonna launchie the hellie out of here. We've got our mobile vehicle bay over with, uh,
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall! I remembered those off of the top my head
I didn't even need to look 'em up!
Jeffrey Billy, Samwise and Marshall...
They're over there by the ship.
In our first base that we built in the shadow of the Aurora.
So what I'm gonna do right now, is I'm gonna retrieve everything that we have
I'm gonna go back to the Sea Emperor's... place.
because apparently, uh
I, uh, I'm not cured.
If I take off this glove here... Lemme show you something.
It's horrible, but uh, let me self-scan, I guess.
Uh-oh.
Yep, I'm infected! Which, if I recall, I was not that way before!
I'm not 100 percent sure...
But I don't remember exactly where we left off, and I wasn't bothered to be checked so
(Screams)
Maybe we can hit that on the way back.
Woah!
Hey, an animation! We got a temperature re--
--Why do we have a temperature reading? Is there some dynamic where--
Uh-oh. It's getting night.
Oh shit that went quick...wai--Whoa whoa whoa whoa oh?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god. That is so cool.
Holy shit.
I mean, I think I know it did that before, but it didn't do that so dramatically.
That is an eclipse of the goddamn everything.
Oh my goodness gravy!
Uhehhhahay
Hey, hang on, let me stand on my Bubblebutt.
Aww, that is so PRETTY!
We got stuff to do. Number one, first and foremost we got to take care of this disease
Which means that we got to go back, all the way to the Sea Emperor's container.
And in the Sea Emperor's container lies the Sea Emperor bay-bies
And in the Sea Emperor bay-bies lie--
I gotta drink my piss here.
(mumbling) Hang on, one second.
(Slurps)
Slurp. Slurpy derp.
Within the Sea Emperor babies lies the cure to the Kharaa virus.
Which means that we won't die if we take those.
So I am assuming that we got to take the Sea Emperor babies...
Crack 'em open, like a... like a lobster
and slurp out the sweet delicious cure from their delicious innards.
That or we need to like, pet 'em and wait for them to poop and then eat their poop.
Either one, I'm willing to take either
I'm not exactly picky right now because I'm about to die,
But, first and foremost, gotta go down there.
And I guess we could hit this lifepod on the way down.
I better not be near anything dastardly.
Doesn't seem too bad.
Going into the Koosh zone here. I don't remember this one being...
Hello? Hi. Was that what I think it was?
Euuuuuh, hey!
Hey! Hey! Back-ie the heck-ie off-ie.
I don't have my defense modules on this and I don't have my big bonkin' Cyclops.
You stay away.
Have I been to you before? Hey? Seapod twelve?
Can you hear me? Any survivors?
Ugh... AH!
Hey. Stop that. Going in here. Don't kill me!
Okay, alright, we're fine.
Hello, aban--Hey!--Ugh, that's scary.
Alright, abandoned PDA. Oh yeah, medical officer. Oh.
Danby: "I'm not really a doctor. I know that's what my ID says, but I never have been."
"Cheated the medical exams."
"What does a doctor these days need to know about manually resetting bones?"
"When was the last time a top surgeon actually cut someone open?"
"That's what the robots are for!"
"Doctors these days read diagnoses off of computer readouts."
"For that, I'm perfectly qualified."
"But what good is it when I'm not connected to the main network?"
"I'm bleeding. I've got glowing green pustules growing on my hands."
"I run a self-scan and it tells me I've got skin irritation."
"The only thing I studied in medical school was how to lie convincingly."
"What the hell do I know about how to treat an alien disease?"
"I think I'm actually going to die down here."
You might be! You might be, considering the fact that you're not here.
Imma assume that you is already dead.
Which means that I (yells) okay.
Tch, maybe you shouldn't have sat yourself next to a volcano.
Ooooh, that's right the geothermal generator.
That is excessively important. Okay, but we're near where we need to be--
Whooaaaa, eeeh.
Oh, that's a volcano.
Ah! Steer clear.
Ah! It's a shockie!
(yelling)
It's a screamie! I'm gonna lose them in the tunnels!
I'm just like Han Solo in the...
(Yells)
Now this is podracing!
Big ol' fi--Ah!
(Varied yelling noises)
Hey, hey, hey, (laughs) no...I did, I missed you.
Did you miss me? I bet you didn't. Although you're gonna.
No. Hey. Wow.
I don't like--I don't like you.
Ah, there it is. Okay.
So it should be on. If it's not on, then I'm boned.
If it i-- it's on.
Okay, I'm not boned. Thought I'd be boned. Not boned
(Wooshing sounds)
That is a scream.
Hello. I'm here. I'm back, baby. Oh.
(gasps)
Wait a minute. You're still alive.
No. I don't want that!
I...
...Thought I've been through this emotional trauma.
Oh no. (sobbing)
Oh no!
I don't know--wait. I have the hatching enzymes, then? Did I do all of that stuff?
I don't remember what I did!
"Insert ion cube", okay?
Yeah.
O-okay. Well, that works now. Oh, hi.
Hey, what's up, Emps? How you doin'?
I don't have... I don't have it anymore?
How do I not have it?
But I went through all the trouble of getting that!
Oh no.
There it is. "Hatching enzymes". But I already went through all the trouble!
I swear I did! I swear!
I went through all the trouble. I got every single thing.
And (laughing) it was a bitch and a half!
Oh my god, and I don't have it?
Son of a tit!
Well.
Alright.
Maybe I did a stupid, like, bold, like,
"I'M GONNA BE BOLD."
Maybe I did a stupid thing where I was like,
"Hey, I'm 'unna not cheat, but also this isn't ready."
That sounds like me. That sounds like I was up my own ass about it--
I just pissed myself. I'm so scared of my true nature.
Okay, alright.
Automated voice: Emergency, starvation imminent. Seek calorie intake immediately.
Eh, shut up! Whatever, I'll just catch a peeper.
Oh, I'm gonna eat ya. I'm gonna eat ya.
The Emperor can't do nothin'. The Emperor can't protect you now!
Okay. Alright. I'm just gonna stuff you right in my gob.
Nom, nom.
Straight up.
Automated voice: Vital signs stabilizing.
Right in my belly.
Yeah, eat you right in front of the Emperor. What do you think of that?
Come here, you. Come here, ya peeper.
I like the way your giant eyeball tastes when I crunch it.
Alright. You stay safe, Emps!
I'm gonna pretend like I don't know what happens and, uh,
We're gonna giddy outta--oh, man I feel so bad.
Big Emps. Big E!
Oh my goodness you're so beautiful.
Alright, I'll be back.
I'll be back.
Alright. We know what we need to do.
We know what we need to do.
And I still hold to the true values that I have.
No cheat-ie. No cheat-ie. No nothing.
'Cause if I cheat-ie I beat-ie myself with the stick.
Now, I got to find these hatching enzymes again, which means that I...
Get to go on a little bit of an adventure.
(Thud)
(Animal roaring, beeping) HUH!? WHOA! WHAT THE FUCK!? HI!? I'M NOT IN MY SHIP!!
Ooooh, where am I?
Where am I?
What the...
Fuck.
Just.
Happened?
*Markimoo makes utterly surprised and confused face*
uuh
close your mouth you might drown
Um.
Ah.
Bubblebutt?
...Where did Bubblebutt go?
(Pew)
What was that?
Did--did like this...
Did, like, the Levi--
HEY!
Ow. Fucking--What the fuck is that?
Seasons(?)
Oh, I don't like this. I don't like this at all.
Where'd Bubblebutt go?
Oh, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
You shitbag. You Warper bitch. What're you doin' here?
Listen. You're not welcome here--
I gotta find Bubblebutt.
Where the fuck did Bubblebutt go?
I don't even understand what happened.
I think, maybe I got grabbed by Leviathan,
But did he destroy Bubblebutt that quickly?
(muttering) What did--how would it...?
What is that? What's what's that over there?
No, that's a vent. Goddammit.
I am dead if...a Leviathan finds me. I am just straight-up dead.
And why is it dark still?
This is a bad place to be.
If that was a Leviathan, then it's not safe to be here and look for Bubblebutt.
I guess I'll come back?
Oh, god damn it!
Goddammit. That was awful.
Bubblebutt was just ripped from my arms!
What the hell happened?
Oh...
Hey!
What the fuck?
Okay, you know that doesn't happen. You don't need to be a scary sack of poop
You just don't need to be that.
You don't need to be that.
We may be able to go find Bubblebutt
But I'm not gonna swim around those oceans with Leviathan around
If that's even what happened to me.
I'm pretty sure that was a Leviathan, but again.
I'm just talking myself in circles trying to rationalize what happened.
Either way, I think I lost Bubblebutt.
Which is bad 'cause that was my fastest method of transportation.
I'm gonna have to make another one I can't--
I can't. I can't name it Bubblebutt.
Bubblebutt.
Bubblebutt's been with me through thick and thin!
Bubblebutt...
I'm legit sad! I'm legit sad about that. I am honestly sad.
Bubblebutt's been with me for so long!
Power cell, glass, lubricant, lead, titanium ingot.
I might have the materials for this over in Big Box Barry
So let me go to Big Box Barry first; kinda threw a wrench into all of my plans
And I know I can go back to my old save but I don't want to do that
Like, I don't want to do that especially on the first episode.
Back on the main game 'cause man that is...
That sucks! That sucks.
But it was my own stupid fault. I was--I was going right through
The Reaper Leviathan territory, and I wasn't even paying attention to where I was going
How did...?
How did it even sneak up on me? You're supposed to be able to hear them.
And was it even that maybe I just hit a rock and I panic got out of my thing?
But I'm pretty sure my--my Seamoth turned around which means that
I dunno...
I just don't know.
I don't know.
Okay, alright. I'm gonna get over this. I'm gonna get over to Big Box Barry,
I'm gonna get the materials necessary,
I'm gonna go back to my first base,
I'm gonna meet up with Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall,
and we gonna get the heckie out of here.
Oh, God look at all the names
Lapisanst, Swagbird, LotsOfPeeps, NinjaCat2, RobinHadx, ScootMax2, Destructo, Shade265
CodyWishOn
And that's the thing that I'm gonna enjoy most about getting back to this game is being able to put you guys  names on
here
And if you don't remember how to get your name on here all you gotta do is comment down some advice, some words of encouragement
A joke that makes me laugh, that's really all they need and then and then we're gonna be back at business
But we have big box Barry
Alright so we got a bunch of stuff a Ruby Ruby when did I get Ruby
Your in alright. I don't remember half of these materials because I don't remember the icons of which they are
Man everything looks so nice now, okay, so we've got everything except for the lead. I know I've got lead
Somewhere in here. I am very
Confident in my lead. I have yes lead. Okay. I've got lead
I don't know if that's enough. It is okay, so we got everything that we need for another
Engine offline well there's a fire that
Thank you
Thank you. I don't think I ever named your voice, but I don't think you need a voice I
Don't even want to give you a voice
You know and I don't care if it's cavitating because I've got all the defense mechanisms needed to not be able to do anything ooh
There you go
Grumbling bumbly, there
Overheating we gotta move fast, baby. We got to get to where we gotta get what are you gonna do blow up?
Alright fine you sack of tits where's my fire extinguisher do I have a fire ex-
I do not have hi. Where's our fire hello, Uh oh glass not good
Yeah, no joke no joke okay. All right. Okay. All right cut the dubstep
Okay, it's fine. It's fine. Everything's fine. What are you? Oh? Oh? I could modify a vehicle there, ooh
Potatoes all right that's fine so the lesson of the day is don't do that because that's who I am
So if I don't do that then I'm not gonna have a problem, and if I don't have a problem
Then I ain't gonna be stupid, and if I ain't stupid I ain't gonna know that
You're not going to get both of my guys oh this is bad oh
Okay, this is a bad idea. This is what I call a bad idea. I need to dock
No, I need to dock. Okay shield up
sonar good
break for silent running oh
We are in trouble. Okay, all right this rescue mission has gone awry. Where's the way the gun doc
I need to get to the gun doc the gun doc there there there there there. There's a doc
I know you know. There's a doc. I've never used it before knots on the other side of this one
Okay, it's going yeah. I'm still gonna use the doc. Just in case
The dubsteps really pounding today oh
It's the same sack of shit, I bet that's the same exact sack of shit that did it last time
Oh that freaking asshole. Okay? I got to take care of some stuff. Oh, I gotta take care of some stuff. Okay. Well oh
God that's not good my potatoes
Oh, no. Oh, no oh no replace my rings. They were to take fire
Okay, all right so repair so
That looks bad, okay, I gotta go outside. Now. Okay. I'll go repair now okay repairing repairing immediately now
Okay, oh, how we looking geez that ass. What did a number on me?
I didn't think that it could hurt me that badly. I mean I know I'm vulnerable now
It's not like I'm immune anymore, but goddamn. Oh really smack this shit out of me
All right crisis averted right he better not be just sucking down power cuz if you are
I'm gonna be so pissed. No I cannot move what no
Wait a minute. I can't move
Excuse me. What did you just decide to reject me as your your captain because what I wasn't doing a good enough job
Protecting you huh? Is that what it? Was. Oh, you're out of power. Oh
Okay, all right. Who is that all how are you out of power? Oh my god? What drained him?
Are you shitting my dick here? What the hell did the shield really drain it that fast?
Oh my god
Are you kidding me that is like the most power suck I've ever seen
Why so much power suck is it because it's charging now and like the toll cheat of charging your thing from the own thing it
Doesn't work anymore is that what it is. That is so much power? I don't like that okay?
That uses a lot of power. I just wasted more. Oh, I'm so boned oh
I'm bone to the extreme. Oh, I'm boned. Oh, I am oh oh
I
Guess they might have fixed the the infinite power thing
They probably did they probably definitely fixed that I am
boned oh
No, okay, well, let's stop the charging because I'm about to die again
stop stop and then
Stop stop stop stop, okay, all right Wow all right
It's so unfair you asshole you took a bubble but for me
Everything I knew and loved is gone
Everything I loved is gone everything. I knew and loved is gone
I'm gonna run out of power. Okay, all right? I
Can do this it's fine. We got this so here's the plan. I've got I've got a new plan
The next few episodes are going to involve me building a new base a brand new base forget
What the old is we're gonna bring in a brand new base
it's gonna be near the aurora again because I know I'm gonna have to go into the aurora for a few more things before I
Finish this off just to see everything that's in there. That's leftover, but I'm gonna build a new base
It's gonna have a better power system so that I can have the ion power cells that I need to be able to flip out
The power for the Cyclops because I guarantee they've gotten rid of the unlimited energy thing that is gone
I don't even know if I can make it back to my base with the amount of energy that I have left and I probably
Can't because it's draining fast right now, so what I need to do is I need to make a new base
and I need to go and
survive
That's all I got to do. I got to survive get the materials for the hatching enzyme avoid Reaper leviathans like the frickin plague
And make it out here alive
So it's gonna be an adventure. We're not through the woods yet
it's not as easy as just hopping on a rocket and getting the hell out of here even though I
Technically do have the materials available to be able to do that
but I can't get those hatching enzymes without bubble butt gotta make bubble butt gotta get new stuff gotta get power up and running and
It all starts with a brand new base, so that's what I'm gonna do in the next episode
So thank you everybody so much for watching it
Let me know down in the comments if you want to be on the next Locker
But only if you give me some cool advice or make fun of me for all of my flights that I've been through
Thank you. Everybody again and as always
See you in the next video. Bye. Bye. I pissed myself